dude I feel so much better as a blonde I
feel so oh thanks for noticing the new
hair David you were blond less I'm no I
wasn't blond the last time I was here
okay Wow Wow never notice anything your
titties look nice today well [ __ ] the
countdown intro but we're gonna do it
anyways 5 4 3 2 1 welcome you sexy sexy
people to another episode of genius
brain podcast we have one of my closest
friends ever
this stupid big-titted [ __ ] Gina Gina
darling what's that one's one birthday
your birthday is the day that sunshine
came to earth that's what you were born
it's good I decided to be happy you
[ __ ] [ __ ]
I really should know you're behind the
camera right now just trying to signal I
25th okay thank you sir I [ __ ] knew
that dude July 25th that is the day the
earth decided to do [ __ ] [ __ ] that's
how you might I'm gonna have a for once
I'm actually have a birthday party
you're gonna have a birthday party I'll
throw for you oh my god did you guys
hear that because I'm actually planning
on throwing something kind of big and
David really no yes yeah are you really
gonna throw you know what is your big
three-o huh what are you gonna do so Tim
and I actually I was talking about this
so [ __ ] Tim right in his birthday was
about a month ago yeah yeah yeah I said
oh [ __ ] him birthday and then like he
responds to me then I say he goes oh
[ __ ] you should have been at the party I
forgot to invite you look like you a
little [ __ ] so we got to talking about
birthdays I want to do a funeral themed
look a funeral for my youth so I want
everyone like it's gonna be like an
all-black party mm-hmm and I want
everyone to show up with like the best
black outfits ever like Gio wants all
the net over her hair
let the net over her face like a
grieving widow and shit's gonna be
[ __ ] dope and they are so [ __ ] extra
I am so extra I am and then I want like
those big balloons that spell out our IP
20 s gonna be dope I'm gonna have like a
[ __ ] like hor d'oeuvres
[Laughter]
that's a hoarders some hoarders [ __ ]
support and horde of arse or artists or
doors
yes important force main on trees what's
with the main on trees and what's the
[ __ ] divorce it's a [ __ ] divorce or
divorce might mean all it's good I would
have men in [ __ ] bowties serving my
[ __ ] divorce
mmm you know what that kind of sounds
fun hmm oh [ __ ]
you have you you've never ever thrown
yourself a birthday party you know what
you're actually a very rare rare breed
that because all the [ __ ] girls that
I know always throw birthdays for
themselves yep like they do it's my
birthday mom yes I'm like the [ __ ] is a
birthday month you got back like you
were born on a single day you don't get
a [ __ ] birthday month you know
there's there's Black History Month you
don't get a month History Month yeah
today is my birthday month Ari what are
you gonna get for my birthday absolutely
nothing you piece of [ __ ] you get
something done I know that because I
grew up with like my early 20s was all
go-go dancers and models it's always a
whole ass birthday month and I'm like
aren't you tired what do they do
do the whole month they have like
multiple dinner parties and they have
like multiple like or they have like
parties have multiple do number and then
have like one big party
mm-hmm and I'm actually gonna steal an
idea from them because what they usually
do is oh my god everyone has to wear
this color okay like everyone is going
and then they show up in pink so they
stand out so for my black party it's
gonna be everyone in black but I want to
wear red oh it's like a satanic vigil
yeah let me dope dope I'm gonna be wild
I am so excited like I told the girls
like everyone like look it's in July and
everyone suggested I want everyone to
like serve drama with their outfit like
I want it to be super extra let me know
well I have mostly black things anyway
so it's gonna be very [ __ ] joggers or
cheap
I'm just hoping a basketball shorts a
t-shirt and flip-flops or socks like
just on purpose I don't even have that
[ __ ] anymore but I'm still gonna find it
I'm gonna dig it up somewhere that's
gonna be [ __ ] fun dude so so you how
come you never celebrated a birthday
because I know I never really did
because my parents never put a big
emphasis on it so what about for you
I just never cared much to like put I
really keep to myself you know like I
really I'm not big on like throwing a
huge party in [ __ ] because people hire
me okay
I don't like big social things and the
older a groom like god I really don't
want to be around people you know cuz I
I spent my early 20s in nightclubs every
weekend oh that's right for work yeah
you were a go-go dancer hey what is a
go-go dancer exactly I never actually
asked you what a what defines a go-go
dancer
so go-go dancing started out in the 70s
and the name go-go
I mean legend has it that it comes from
a bar in in Hollywood called Oran West
Hollywood called West whisky a go-go oh
and that's apparently that's where go-go
dancer started and go-go dancers are
basically the girls who dance onstage at
nightclubs or like in those bird cages
those giant cages and yeah yeah go-go
boots on like the thigh high boots I
think 70s dress and then go-go boots
they're basically like atmosphere
dancers so like and one said well that's
a stripper I'm like no [ __ ] like the
[ __ ] verb strip is literally in the
word stripper you dumb [ __ ] but so if
we're just like atmosphere models of
anything we dance we get the crowd hyped
up and stuff and I love like that was my
most perfect job when I was younger
because one you get paid a pretty good
amount to I get to exercise and I hate
exercising that was the only one that I
liked and three I got to wear cute
outfits and four no one talks to me
you're on because you're just dancing
yeah and no one bothers me and it's
[ __ ] swim did you ever have an
experience where a guy would try to grab
you yes I've gotten into fights and
clubs because of that oh [ __ ] yeah you
ain't got teeth
[Laughter]
know how you go take that risk we got my
gun to death so prior to this she was
telling me this mystery we got teeth
well she does have teeth but heard
apparently your dentist no my
orthodontist all four doctors all four
Dantas [ __ ] up my teeth and I was
younger because Vietnamese people right
we like to bargain right so somehow my
family bargained for the orthodontist to
take my braces cuz braces I think are
cosmetic but somehow they said like oh
no no it's isn't that so they got it
covered by insurance and that's what I'm
assuming why he went [ __ ] super cheap
on him because he ended up moving my
teeth too fast and when that happens
your roots kind of shorten gradually so
last year I went to a dentist I was like
yeah I wanna get veneers done he looks
at me he goes no you don't I'm like why
he goes your teeth are not I've noticed
this for a long time I thought I was
normal for some reason he said my roots
are a lot shorter than what like within
my teeth are out here like the teeth
that you see the roots are a lot shorter
than the two thing crazy so you think
that's what like my tooth has never been
still like it's it's always wobbled a
little bit my two front teeth and what
made you think that was normal [ __ ]
grabbing people's - what kind of flawed
[ __ ] is that dude so every time you
smile you're slightly shifted and you're
like that's what it is it's like a
tectonic plates on in the earth shift so
he's like you can't get veneers put over
these you have to do full implants so I
have to pull out like you're like the
four six people here and and then that
the implant process [ __ ] sucks did
they yank it all out wait for it to heal
they drill holes in it put in these
metal things wait for that to heal and
wait for it and make sure that my body
doesn't reject it and then they screw in
the new teeth so this is gonna be a
whole like it's like a ten thousand
dollar thing that I'm doing right now so
we're okay hold on a second so how long
is this process then so how long are you
gonna be front teeth zoom no they give
you like temporary like tea that you pop
in okay but I'm telling you whoever
wants to date me at that time
right if some job ever did if you want a
[ __ ] denture adventure let's [ __ ]
go you definitely won't feel the teeth
on the big dude nothing there nice soft
gum I'm like gum your dick to death I
can't wait for those pictures dude I
can't wait for those pictures with you
without your teeth I'll never share them
but I'll die laughing I'm like a farmer
Alphen just dude that should it be so
[ __ ] funny you should do a photo
shoot where you're still sexiest buckle
without teeth oh my god you know I
should do can we do like a trap video
like a thirst trap video just like ah
just like squeeze my boobs and then all
of a sudden I smile and then BAM I would
[ __ ] die dude
I wonder if guys would actually care for
a girl didn't have teeth like I can't be
do with no teeth what you mean [ __ ]
[ __ ] okay I ain't know how shallow I am
you telling me that you can like if you
like if someone set you up on a blind
date and she was fine as [ __ ] and the
[ __ ] has like like four missing tooth
up and down I'll tell you this I would
look past her teeth of look into her
heart do the gaps of routine I will look
past there's the caps of her teeth and I
was i'll move past that tonsil and I'll
look into the spirit of her soul and I
will see she's a good person I don't
know man it's so weird because I think
that we we always tell ourselves that
we're not superficial but we definitely
do have are certain things that we can't
move past like for me
sadly bad skin Baskin [ __ ] me up yeah
like bad skin now I'm not talking about
a few pimples here and there or you're
like some acne and stuff like that but
like really bad skin kind of turns me
off yeah I mean it sucks for people who
have asked and I'm us guys nothing great
but then it does bother me maybe it was
good I don't work
Muriel Muriel has been working on it a
lot so she taught me about toner lotion
[ __ ] scrubs and [ __ ] and then mass
clay mass all this other [ __ ] right I
didn't know about this Darian woman dude
straight up I don't know how crusty I
was no guys don't know how crusty now
because in our world everything's fine
and then it's like one of those like
glass shattering moments where after she
mentioned it to me I've never been able
to look back she goes by the way your
face is dry [ __ ] you talking about my
face is dry oily skin she goes yeah but
you have crusts all over the paper again
every time I looked into the mirror I
was like what the [ __ ] is that and I
didn't realize that when I would wash my
face I thought it was normal that your
skin would just feel like okay tight
yeah she just learned that too I told
her you're not supposed to feel tight
yeah I didn't know that so you're
supposed to use toner and it's supposed
to whatever you know yeah balance the pH
[ __ ] on your face and then use lotion to
moisturize it and then every now and
then like I started using um some people
say is good or bad start using retinol
I've been using that for like fine lines
and [ __ ] but it [ __ ] really helped my
skin now like after a week the retinol
[ __ ] I was like yo look at my [ __ ]
face - it looks good
Darrell's [ __ ] crazy like yes you use
it from like when you're young all what
I never stop yeah it's so good it's
[ __ ] good and oh by the way when you
use retinol do not use it during the
daytime Oh sunscreen so he's been using
Sun using the sunscreens yeah the
sunscreen put a lot of screens on the
sunscreens and also you're supposed to
reapply it every like 2 or 3 hours -
when you put on do you have a
recommendation oh look at this we do in
bitched on a recommendation for a
sunscreen that's not oily yes I have I
like matted sunscreens I use the Biore
ones the Asian Biore ones you're gonna
send me a link that [ __ ] cuz like the
one that I have it's it's light but it's
people losing a lot of mad respect for
me right now
respect you but it makes me shiny
I don't like this [ __ ] so and you have
to make sure that you're applying
sunscreen properly too because a lot of
people think like if you put on a lot
just like rub it in there it's gonna
work it actually makes it worse you're
supposed to put it on and just like
smooth it on because it's supposed to be
a layer on top of your skin not rubbed
in and then there's also like for women
who have makeup on obviously you can't
rub sunscreen on like a way through the
day their sunscreen sprays I know so I
mean like I've been going hard with this
[ __ ] in the last like four years yeah
your skin looks [ __ ] good it looks
really good yeah I noticed in the
pictures I just kid it looks [ __ ]
smooth his [ __ ] you know and that's the
thing too by the way if you think this
is some weird [ __ ] guys out there if you
don't take care of your skin you're
going to regret it later on because what
they say about skin is that you can you
can't turn back the hands of time but
you can prevent things from happening so
if you don't start now
your face is gonna look like a baseball
mitt you don't look like Gordon Ramsay
mm-hmm and that fools face looks like a
direct scrotum
I Love You Gordon I love Gordon too but
I think you're beautiful but I love oh
really yes
oh really like look it's like I like the
angry British or its kind of [ __ ] hot
that's daddy right there his face looks
like a wallet no but it's true that like
if you guys haven't looked there's a
there's a there's a there's a picture on
Google it's called like a a truck
drivers face and like this is old man
who's been driving like semi trucks his
whole life cross country and you know
how you sit on your left side so the
sun's always on your left side
yeah his left side is like this oh
really yeah just that side because the
Sun damaged so that's like dude you need
like if anything you can't do anything
for your face at all just put on
sunscreen
yeah like before I started doing like
the whole face regimen thing like I kid
you not the funny thing is most people
when they get into a relationship they
tend to digress they look worse and
worse since I got my man I look better
and better because she's been she's been
tweaking me to better suit her needs
right she goes yeah he's really out of
shape I'm getting the work out a little
bit he doesn't drink enough water to
drink some water so she's been like
tweaking me and [ __ ] dude and so like
after I started using lotion now I can't
go without using lotion yes it's very
very apparent like your skin just gets
worse and worse than
worse like there's more acne and it's
weird because like my skin has that oily
combination
I'm combination yeah I [ __ ] hate it
it's annoying so what you do with that
is you treat the area by what you need
so I'll put a different mask on my oily
areas and a different mask on my my
drier areas oh it's been like the
problem with me though when I really get
into something we invested into
something I go [ __ ] over [ __ ] you
know I have like four thousand dollars
worth of skincare in my house right now
and my cute my daily routine is that
that was another routine what yeah I
should smooth my creams and stuff my
dreams in my lotions and my lotions and
then also so I started if you notice
look at my look at my my my eyebrows
when I found oh yeah I don't look angry
I just look slightly concerned yeah a
Botox with my brows right now oh really
it freezes the muscles here so I can't
really like frown properly so I was so I
went to this uh you can't be angry I can
be concerned I'm like slightly you'd
like a consistent goal I'm so skeptical
right now you just made me so scary and
so I go to this the skin
shoutout to Beauty Bar clinics I love
you holy crap hi ash I love you um but
so this girl she was like she was doing
Junction's on my face right my botox and
this is crazy I can't believe I've
reached the stage where like we're all
getting Botox and [ __ ] like whole I'm
gonna I'm about to be a [ __ ] like OC
housewife I'm [ __ ] the pool boy while
getting Botox parties and [ __ ] I'm so
excited
anyways so you know though I heard a lot
of dudes do a Botox in this and yeah
Moorhead area a lot of people do Botox
so I was looking at her while she was
doing my my face I was like dude she's
[ __ ] pretty like she's like this
Filipino girl she was Filipino in
Portuguese oh damn dude you're [ __ ]
pretty she's so nice I'm like I'm 72
years old she's 30 she was like 33 she
looked like she was 24 I was like what
the [ __ ] she goes I've been in this
business long time she's been a Botox
and she was like 21 because that's
preventative you know cuz it freezes
your muscles so that you're like um so
it doesn't cause like constant
movement like that and causing those
wrinkles right here like here is where
you would see it a lot of people get it
around their eyes they yeah yeah and I
started getting it done because now that
I'm streaming a lot more I realized that
when I'm playing games my focus face I
get I look angry when I'm focused I
think I'm sure oh my brows a lot and
then my viewers were like oh she like
was she focuses she looks angry and then
I was like all [ __ ] you're right and my
worst habit is me frowning that's why I
was like I should probably take care of
this now and like be more you gonna be
doing Botox forever how much is that how
much does it cost it depends on how much
you get so for instance I went to a
doctor before one session was like 1500
bucks
it's pretty pricey dude Oh at last
I'm like four to six months oh if you're
lucky it's actually pretty long yeah
yeah I thought it was like a month but
more to six-month that make sense yeah
so if you're lucky so it's like and you
know like sometimes I come in like yeah
a little bit of tweaking here and there
just like Botox whatever but my thing is
like I don't like it noticeable like I'm
not about to [ __ ] come out like fat
ass lips and [ __ ] you know yeah yeah
yeah yeah what the [ __ ] actually can you
tell what I've gotten done um I don't
know I don't really look at your face
often but I think I don't know I have to
take I have to stare at you I've given
I've gotten one too did you do like I've
gotten five spots injected move the mic
from your face [ __ ] man I can't tell
though like I think maybe on your this
area mm-hmm and that's probably the only
thing that's noticeable yeah but barely
though and that's only because I've seen
your face for years yeah so my thing is
like I like to enhance not change so
I've gotten my cheeks lifted up a little
bit here so I wouldn't I would have
never noticed that I have a little bit
on my chin here to fill it out more yeah
I have a little bit of my chin to bring
it out more and then I have them that
what they do is Botox in your Massa ders
and this like it Massa ders what the
[ __ ] you're chewing muscles no chew and
muscle Slim's it down so for you so for
you what made you want to start doing it
oh just because like
well num 1 yours is very settled right
so what made you want to start doing it
because working at entertainment yeah
you have to like as a woman you have to
be you know like you have to look a
certain way you know I mean and also
because I'm [ __ ] shallow [ __ ] like
if I'm ugly I'm gonna kill myself
[Laughter]
because you know like no [ __ ] like if
I'm ugly I'm a [ __ ] jump off a bridge
that's not like we're not gonna [ __ ]
lie here just to let you know it's not
worth it I have dreams of being like
that the come Munna Oh God not like
extreme but I want to be like that old
Korean lady that's like I'm gonna give
you an age cutoff your age cutoff for
for these modifications is 45 that is
your age no 50 because I'm Asian to 50
that is an age cutoff because I feel
like like certain además that I've seen
grow up like they they started doing a
little later in their life obviously but
at the age of 50 like I feel like you
can still look good and just let it go a
little bit you know what I mean like it
my mom like I had a conversation with my
mom and she was like haha I might want
to try doing this and that's likely you
don't need any mess stuff like you I was
like number one I know like like do you
feel bad she goes no I don't and I was
like that's life you know and for me too
it's like it is what it is like you you
know you raise two boys you you know
came to this country you [ __ ] killed
it like whatever dude like don't [ __ ]
trip about that type of [ __ ] and for me
to I think for my mom if I see and I
come back and it's not her face that she
would break my heart oh it's not my
mom's face ya know so like if I saw that
I think I would die
yeah cuz I don't it's not something the
the warm face that I grew up with you
know now before we continue my friends
this podcast is brought to you by
Sanford now have you ever walked down
the street and have a random stranger
come up to you and say you know what
dude
you smell good I guarantee you that's a
no because you haven't heard of scent
bird now for me check this out I like to
smell different all the time
and what I mean by that is have you ever
bought a bottle of cologne and after you
used it you found out two years later
you still have 70% of it left because
you know dang well you're not gonna use
that gajillion ounce bottle of cologne
and after a while maybe and even after a
few months you want to smell different
you're tired of smelling the same way
and you still want to smell good well
guess what my friends sent Byrd is gonna
fix that for you now for me if you're
asking
well David how do you choose your scent
well when I go on scent bird calm and I
want to choose the fragrances I want
this is what I do I don't look at the
name brands I go by the types of smell
that I enjoy they have that search
engine option for me I click citrus I
click sandalwood I click bergamont fresh
clean smells and from that list I choose
my colognes and ladies that goes for you
with your perfumes as well well check
this out you can choose the clone you
want to try and they'll also send you a
30-day supply that's a hundred and
twenty sprays enough to apply more than
four times daily for a month to keep you
smelling fresh and with an exclusive
offer just for our listeners you can get
50% off your first month today that's
only 750 for your first fragrance go to
scent bird comm / brain and use my code
brain for 50% off your first month again
that's scen t-bird dot-com / brain for
you to get your first cologne or perfume
for just 750 my friends sign on and
smell amazing sad bird but you're young
I guess I think it's like I want to
enjoy all this while I still can you
know like [ __ ] it let's just my thing is
like you're born here with one vessel
and just [ __ ] decorate it however you
want stop changing your face so much you
can tell I don't give up [ __ ] stop
changing the [ __ ] face I finally go
to Korea I get plastic surgery come back
and you still won't notice and you'll be
like sitting there like change your face
like [ __ ] I already did it's been like
six months don't you change your face
your hair wasn't blonde the last time
yeah it was not blind I feel like I'm a
better person when I'm blonde I feel
lighter
you look good with with light hair
though right there's a lot of girls who
um it's weird who just looked better
with light I think jess is one of them
she looks really great with highlights
like wish yeah when she when she put in
like the blond highlights and their
strawberry blonde look I liked a lot
better than her darker hair you look
very well cuz she has very fair skin too
so I [ __ ] with it a lot
I love it on her she looks really pretty
dude dude I [ __ ] love Jess D did you
know that all the JK girls are in a
group chat oh yeah I heard about that
only recently yeah it's like the best
group chat ever
dick pics are in there what the [ __ ]
defects that we enjoy actually did you
see this thing did you see that day look
at this stick this stick is awesome
look at this one it's great the vein
[ __ ] this way and the vein goes this
way the worst part about this [ __ ]
group chat is that all the girls will be
talking about like sex [ __ ] right uh-huh
Julia would come in drop a [ __ ] bomb
and then leave and we're just like what
the [ __ ] did you say and I'm just like
and then all of a sudden I'm pulling at
a rosary and praying for her like it's
[ __ ] weird every time we see like
because it'll show like Oh Julia is
typing oh [ __ ] is she gonna say
clutching my pearls scared it's so weird
because there are definitely women
within the JK crew that like Julia is
one of them what it's hard for me she's
definitely a woman right but like jokes
explained it best like we pictured her
as like this snot-nosed girl yeah with
boogers and grass coming out right so
comic books and she's stuck on her
issues she's a very beautiful girl girl
you know and just for us because we saw
her when she was so young
it's just not it's just it doesn't
really click yeah you know what I mean
and even for me and for you
like so back in the day she this girl
confronted me she goes so why aren't you
[ __ ] following me on his to grab him
you know like I wanted to fight him hold
the [ __ ] up so I remembered why I had
followed you I unfollowed you because at
this time there wasn't an ability to
mute post it's because you you had so
many pictures of you naked and I
couldn't I couldn't
it was just very risque it was very nice
she looked great but I don't want to see
that yeah you know so I was like and I
don't fought I didn't follow a lot of
people so your folks posts were very
frequent all my stuff just pussy's up I
can't see this [ __ ] you know I even
noticed you unfollowed me
it's fans that were like yo I just
looked at David's followings did you
realize that he doesn't follow you like
what the [ __ ]
the love was still there it's just I
couldn't see you
just just spread-eagle a month from now
I'm gonna [ __ ] post a photo that
simply says Dave are you still following
me and I'm gonna check in every few
months and you better [ __ ] go man
I've recently gotten over it I've got
I've gotten over it I'm like this is
fine I know that feeling about like it's
like when you know someone's yeah like
my sister I'm about to [ __ ] throw her
[ __ ] under the bus right now I watch
watch imma throw her under the bus right
now so Sam don't kill me for this okay
and what's it though you should under
bus right now so I was on a date with
the guy once and yeah how long ago this
was I was on a date with a guy once I
have a policy if I'm on a date I
understand the no phone rule whatever I
don't give a [ __ ] if it's family I'm
answering it right I was on a date at
dinner sitting at the dinner table
having a nice conversation and I see her
name pop up on my phone it's a text
message and she says hey do you remember
that one thing he told me not to do that
if I did you would [ __ ] kill me I'm
like yeah well I mean no I I say that a
lot she goes so I lost my virginity and
like time Stood Still and I just stared
at my phone and I was like what the [ __ ]
did you just say to me and then she's
like yeah she did me free she doesn't
remember this she doesn't
I remember it though would you lose your
virginity - yeah you cumber apiece she's
had she's always had long-term
boyfriends yes I'm never worried about
her getting like just like like like
screw and random dudes whatever right
yeah so I knew it was cuz she was with
him for a while I think and no excuse me
that's so sweet
did you say listen listen listen but she
ended up with him they've been together
for like five years now
Wow yeah I know it was and then the
worst [ __ ] part was what I told her I
was like what the [ __ ] did this happen
and she goes um to be honest with you a
year ago and I swear to god dude I
almost flipped the [ __ ] table and
cried she was old enough you know she
was like 18 or whatever and then but
then like to me in my mind like what
julia's she will always be like like 11
years old [ __ ] dumb yeah but like
it's weird like I was just talking to
recently I'm like dude you have like a
full-on like career going as a woman
doesn't work so she era she got a
promotion just a base account she has
heard base accounts she's got taxes she
got [ __ ] benefits and [ __ ] like it's
weird to me cuz whenever she comes to
visit me she's like this dumb ass kid on
my bed just watching cartoons crumbs all
over my [ __ ] bed you know it's a very
strange it's very surreal you know like
even when I see like my friends kids
grow up and they're dating in June you
know what the [ __ ] is going on like I
got emotional the other day because I
saw a video of me and Isaac and he was
on my back and I was like giving a
piggyback ride
and I just I was like oh [ __ ] he got
bracing oh fix his teeth and his big
[ __ ] I said go get his big sex God
some [ __ ] lecherous [ __ ] girl she
was like takis dust all over me some
[ __ ] crazy as Chicana weird it was a
baby he would like whenever he sees me
he comes up any hugs me still kind of
shy now he's like a [ __ ] he's tall
dude he started like creeping me out
when I saw Isaac and he started forming
like real adult sentences cuz before
it's like oh I'm hungry I'm loopy
whatever now it's like yeah I don't
think I like that and the reason why
would you be the reason why yeah the
reason reason yeah when they grow up
dude my little cousin that I used to
share a room was Derek like when in high
school I shouldn't ruin him cuz he's
like this eight-year-old idiot
like he is he's 21 now he streams video
games and that's what he does for work
now my dude what the [ __ ] is so [ __ ]
weird dude it's weird and he's taller
than me maybe it's I think I even have a
cousin he's like 28 29 I mean he 28 he's
he's a grown-ass man he has a job and
stuff but no matter what I can't not see
him as a kid no so I still treat him
like a child you know and our age gap is
like [ __ ] 2 or 3 years you know but
when I look at him to me he just he's
just like this little [ __ ] kid but
this guy's like a go-getter you know has
his own car apartment just working two
jobs [ __ ] the kids like a [ __ ]
grown-ass man dude it's so weird
watching him and that's what it's like
with Julia yeah in the group chat she
come in drop a [ __ ] bomb like y'all
have a [ __ ] suck dick in the car and
where's like excuse me I can't even
imagine like this is what this is watch
me watch this right now
I'm gonna try to pick the Julia naked
right now no I guess what I happened so
she has her clothes right so she has
this little sweater with a Pikachu right
she has her Pikachu hat on she got her
little blue jeans on energy little
[ __ ] Skechers or whatever I don't
know her [ __ ] chucks she takes off
her sweater guess what's underneath her
sweater
right another sweater and inside that
Pikachu sweaters a Bulbasaur sweater
right then she takes off her hat I guess
what's underneath her hat another
[ __ ] hat she takes off her pants
guess what's on her pants another pair
of pants it's just like the neverending
onion yeah that's what it is and so like
you know when she told that story before
where she was she had butt sex yeah oh I
like I was offended I was like who
[ __ ] you again
I also [ __ ] killed him dude that guy
is actually her boyfriend now yeah so
that was her first boyfriend is actually
her boyfriend now is her boyfriend yeah
so we actually talked about in a
different podcast but the night but the
audio [ __ ] [ __ ] up so we have we
haven't be able to release that but we
might release it just as a bonus episode
but she talks about it later on but that
was actually her first boyfriend so
that's only was I could tell the stories
because she actually said on my podcast
yeah yeah but it's so strange it's like
you know what I imagine it's like you
know how like Winnie the Pooh has a
t-shirt on and that's it it's like I'm
taking it off but it's like it's still
Europe you know like it's not sexual
anyways it's so odd and she's such a
she's such a sweet girl and like
like you would read in comments and I
look at Julia's titties I liked it she
got titties those are pokeballs under
their thumb was hiding into her sweaters
as old that's a ziploc bag full of jello
what you talking about the girls are all
[ __ ] talking like dick dick dick dick
[ __ ] dick and then Julia chops a bomb
and the chat just goes quiet for a
second and we just all freaked out this
you girls are a bunch of horndogs
yeah do that chat is so awesome I love
that that's so funny cause like I bet
Jake hey guys don't talk like that yeah
a lot of people think like guys talk
like that no dude it's the girls yeah
and I think like us guys do that we
don't really talk about that [ __ ] like
we just kind of like whatever and I
don't know why but it would be very
weird for me to hear about sexual
conquests that they've had with a girl
that I'm that I'm know that I'm close to
now if it was some random girl that's a
different thing because I don't have any
like emotional connection to her unless
they you know like that's why I never
watched ask the fields I couldn't I
couldn't watch it yeah I clicked on it
once and and it was something about like
I [ __ ] geo like eating coming over
scarred me I was like clicks out me we
don't click out at this point we all
don't click out because today we got a
group text from Tim and all the girls
he's like oh [ __ ] I forgot to send you
this photo so it's a photo of the like
the four of us like meet if Gio Shannon
he's like I forgot to send you this from
the wedding and then so everyone I go
thanks Anne Shannon goes I heard about
this group text or this group chat by
the way I want in
is there an application process because
we recently just let bows in oh yeah
yeah bows must be [ __ ] funny but this
is great I love to shout to Bozeman
she's one of my favorite people on earth
like she makes me happy
yeah like I feel like if anyone would
make bows like even mildly
inconvenienced I would want to kill them
Smosh but and it sounds like I want in
and then now we have to like we have to
consult the you know like the art table
you have to consult the committee let
him in our Rose is shot and allowed to
come in the candles
mayhaps we have a giant book of me
Shannon if you wish to be a part of us
slice your hand and shake ours with the
cut of our cotton may our blood unite it
used to be called a host base uh-huh
that was the name of the group then we
changed it recently to the restroom
because drunk girls at a club in the
bathroom are the most supportive [ __ ]
you'll ever meet in your life
did I I said it's like the stand-up said
about the shits like it's kind of like I
notice how girls hype each other up like
guys don't do that [ __ ] for each other
like girls are the [ __ ] funniest
people on earth like I see girls like
when I see Mary we'll get ready and her
best friends with her - they're like oh
my God look at those earrings you look
good you're always gonna get this
earring for you but I thought it would
be better for [ __ ] Jess so I look
better on her but let me tell you
something the hoop that you have on are
[ __ ] crazy oh my god where the [ __ ]
did you get those palms dude I was I
wasn't sure about it right and so okay
so the other day right so I was trying
and you guys go on this diatribe and
then like oh my god your [ __ ] titties
are great today really you think so I
wasn't feeling that good you're [ __ ]
stupid I would [ __ ] the [ __ ] out of you
right now if I was a guy I remember when
I wasn't I was like I was in Taiwan for
a month for it go gig and then I was
dating and one said his name our mutual
yeah yeah yeah yeah yes I used to date
one of David's friends but um I remember
I haven't seen him like a month he said
yo send me a booty pic I'm like I got
you I told my girlfriend I was like yo
my man means an ass photo she's like I
got you and she's like hittin in all
angles like that's like girls are
supportive when we want to be it's
awesome that's so [ __ ] funny dude I
mean like a make up group right and one
of the girls like hey I won't let you
guys know if you want to cover up any um
marks that your parents don't want to
see you use this I had dinner with my
mom she didn't see a thing and then I
comment I was like damn now we can all
ho in peace this is great like
you guys are such disgusting creatures
did you guys are so [ __ ] I love it so
much because like like I love I love
women who are so just like they have a
firm grasp on their sexuality like
Shannon like is a goddess to me
vibrators yeah dude like she is a
goddess to me and I love people like I
get her on you I have so many questions
about women Shannon what was the
clitoris
where's the clitoris do you know when I
was in fifth grade they had sex ed class
they were teaching her they separated
the girls and they were teaching girls
how to put tampons and use pads and
stuff like that and I was the only one
that raised my hand and said excuse me
what's a vagina and she the ladies look
at me she goes um the bigger hole and
I'm sitting there but I'm like there's
more than what I could watch who holds
this do and then like everyone's are
laughing around me I was like I said you
[ __ ] know what the [ __ ] vagina is
like you don't [ __ ] know but I was
that kid okay the [ __ ] it's it's well
Bart didn't even [ __ ] know there was
two holes Bart didn't know there was a
pee hole in a regular vagina did that's
just [ __ ] hilarious dude I crazy so
the funny thing is like for me
like when people ask me like you how did
you so I'm very open when it comes to
like sexual things like number one and I
learned this only from one [ __ ] girl
so when I was younger guys are so funny
because guys always talk about their
sexual Cudi's the hero in their own
story specifically guys when it comes to
their sexual conquests right I've always
talked about this before is and because
of that type of rhetoric you like young
men I believe they feel pressure to be
like the best at sex like they have to
[ __ ] smash the [ __ ] out the [ __ ]
park on their first try right because
the guys never talk about how bad they
were the first [ __ ] time and they
always think that they're amazing and a
lot of the times I think when girls are
really young they feel like it's their
responsibility to kind of boost up this
guy self-esteem when they [ __ ] right so
there's this Filipino girl that I was
with she was very hyper sexual and our
relationship actually didn't work out
because of how hyper sexual she was and
in in her sense she actually related
affection with sexuality so if we
weren't [ __ ] every day she thought
that something was wrong with us
because the guy says she was with the
only the way they would connect with her
is that they would [ __ ] her for me it
was never like that number one at that
time I was trying to be a stand-up comic
do music I was working two [ __ ] jobs
and I was doing all this other [ __ ] so
Manhasset yeah you know and so for her
but they would they would they would
[ __ ] consistently and I remember when we
broke up or when we had this talk about
that after but when we had sex yeah let
me tell you is funny I was like I asked
her I was like how was it she was like
what you what you mean man what what
what man mean what was many what you
mean man as in me as in like you was
[ __ ] me or you say like me eh like
man like whatever she's like it was okay
yeah but she was very open and honest
with me she's like just like you just
kind of like you just kind of [ __ ]
just the [ __ ] outside
but I didn't know because nobody was
honest with me about that and that at
that point she was like my third or
fourth sexual partner and prior to that
nobody said anything right and I think
it's because they were they were
catering to my ego and mind you that's
because I think a lot of guys need their
ego stroked yeah right so maybe I've
just been always a little weird so I
just well I'll say okay well [ __ ]
tell me how to do this right there
because I don't [ __ ] know I don't
know so you tell me so [ __ ] yeah my
[ __ ] scroll out I got a [ __ ]
Chinese started write calligraphy what
the hell you mean
okay clitoris this way okay figure eight
around the [ __ ] back to the clearest
okay okay maybe look the [ __ ]
sometime okay okay a little what hold
your okay butthole butthole butthole
butthole okay
ok finger here finger here put the mouse
on the critters there wait till you'll
come don't come so early
yeah it's sure though because like as a
woman I've been in that situation where
they're like oh how is it I really want
to say you know you [ __ ] sucked but
like it's like because then men are so
they like the society always
like men are so sensitive about their
death game they really are though they
are you know that's not even like
that's not there's no [ __ ] debate
about yeah but it's like men have to be
accepting of critique too
you know it's like if I tell it like for
instance I actually like there's a one
guy that I was dating spoke about him
before words like this is the smallest
penis I've ever seen in my life like if
I were to hold it in my hand it did not
pop out in the top yeah mm-hmm you know
I made a mistake because that was a guy
I was like you know what sorry like I
like I told her I was like I don't
really have sex like I'm not a first
date [ __ ] God made him wait like three
months okay and then after three months
it was like three months of buildup and
then catastrophic failure yeah I mean if
it let me see the palm on your head
that's oh so it would like be here oh
she's so he has like a micro penis like
it was my you small oh okay so it's like
it's like a and then the thing was okay
you know what if you're small it it's
all the times it doesn't have to do with
the size it is about the motion you know
but this fool was like oh my dick is big
yeah
no he did cuz I think he slightly knows
that he's not that big but okay so let
me see how do I [ __ ] do it
little sister your muffs alright so you
know like when you're hitting it from
behind the girls like it's not right
you're not supposed to like you're
supposed to sit up straight and just hit
that [ __ ] but he was just like lean over
and hug me and it's like yo you don't
have not a lot of length to work with
yeah you can't you're supposed to he's
supposed to sit straight right now but
he's like like do I pretty much hugging
me from behind I'm like yo like you need
to sit up you know I mean and then
afterwards it'll be like so how was it I
was like well your it didn't go in it's
like this is the first time I've ever
been able to say that I've never felt
I'd like I couldn't feel anything
and it was like leeway so what the [ __ ]
was he feeling cuz if you're hugging
from the back like you could only well
he was till he was in but it wasn't like
you know work so and then I would tell
him like you okay so and then so I would
wait and wait until he says is there
anything I should change I'm like oh my
god yes okay anyway you know
okay this what you got to do you got to
chop off whatever you have now and then
just give up give up and then like he
always asked like yeah like it was good
Holly tell me I'm biggest her like you
you it was I'm just like and he never
sent me a dick pic
you G like that huge dick yeah but it's
not and I love like me when I'm dating
someone I love dick pics yeah look when
I'm dating someone okay so stop it stop
setting me dick pics - all right stop
sending us dick pics all right [ __ ] that
have to be dating you okay just don't
send it to me in general if you want to
take pics sent to me please forward it
to David so comedy on Instagram oh
absolutely not
it's a [ __ ] lutely not but like he
was only with the idea that never sent
dick pics because he wasn't proud of his
parcel he knew you know but it's just
like well how did you make adjustments
for it then after after he yes you home
my my adjustment was faking it oh really
yeah for how long for like about like
eight months a long time thanks Kevin
after a while I realized like he lied
about a lot of [ __ ] like dick small
anyways amount by damn eight months and
you had that you had bad sex wasn't
worse but he didn't he didn't do
anything else aside from that cuz
there's so much other things that you
could do it was alright I mean like and
even when I gave him pointers he always
went back to what he was comfortable
with I'm like dude you're not even
making effort to improve that sucks you
know so I didn't work out like it when
sex is bad like the relationship is
[ __ ] dead like I can't do it oh yeah
you can take off your mouth now love you
hahaha I feel like a lot of people live
I know a couple of people that got
divorced because they couldn't match up
sexually yeah and I didn't realize how
it's important in war that is you know
and you know the way these guys talk to
when they're like I'm now man go I used
to smash ticks all the time they've you
know but sight of the world what
obviously it's not true because what the
[ __ ] happened with your marriage you
know and all that stuff comes out you
know it all comes out dude I know a
couple I went to Hawaii for a wedding a
few months Aaron though like a couple
years ago with my ex-boyfriend yeah and
um oh [ __ ] no not Barton Gio's weddings
I've been a to Hawaii weddings and I was
like you know we were
anyone talking then I was with a group
of girls and the wife's and stuff like
that and the girlfriends and then
they're like oh yeah tell them about how
you liked Ellen's woman's call her Angie
right
oh yeah the Angie tell us about how your
husband and you like [ __ ] the closet
and she was drunk she's like I don't
want to talk about it [ __ ] like
that's all we got going on anyways like
oh [ __ ] I was like oh [ __ ] she's like
that's the only thing keeping this
[ __ ] relationship together I was like
and this is like a chick with kids oh
she's like so sad it is so sad
that's [ __ ] yeah I was like oh my god
okay I mean I guess but damn that sucks
but other than that they never like see
eye to eye what's right and Friends she
said straight up she's like no her words
were that's all we got going anyways
where I've been friends
damn dude I saw it I was like I am never
getting married
and if I do I hope I never be like you
guys that [ __ ] sucks well let's go back
to you so in when you were with that guy
right so for eight months you just the
sex wasn't good so what kept it going on
for not to say that sex is everything
but that is a huge part I mean it's how
it's it's it's to me like sometimes to
me sex is almost like an emotional
refresher mm-hm
right because it really goes back to
just kind of because emotional sex is
big for me right now so I've never been
to do that that was able to [ __ ] around
too much like if I did it's because I
went through a really long dry spell you
know and then I just kind of just saw
like [ __ ] it whatever like whatever you
know but for you within that eight
months if the sex was that bad what kind
of kept you there cuz I feel like a
physicality is a big part for you yeah
we were actually really good friends we
got along so well I was friends and we
actually at the end when we broke up we
sat there ruling do you think about how
you know it'd be [ __ ] dope friends
he's like yeah actually I do it was like
you would just he's like yeah you know
what yeah probably
and it's true like we were don't friends
everything else was great like we would
laugh together we had the same jokes
everything was like it's cool you know
well no I mean like personality-wise
that was good you know so at the end
were like I think you and I would be
dope friends he's like yeah me too and
then that's how I broke up oh that's
pretty good I mean yeah guys are just so
fixated on the size thing like it's it's
it's it's a it's like a big center of
conversation
I don't know if it's because guys put a
lot of emphasis on it or is it because a
lot of women put a lot of support it's
what they learn from porn and
advertisements that because importantly
people have unrealistic expectations ya
know so that's the funny thing so like I
mentioned this story before where I have
a friend of high school and I'm not sure
if it's a reflection of the stuff that
she either she was watching or what she
expected out of a guy's size but this
was so [ __ ] weird so we were all just
chilling you know we're taught we're
friends and we're just sharing like
stupid stories and she's talking about
oh she and she needs to have like a
really good-sized dick to have let's
have good sex I were like okay cool hey
what's a good size station you know just
something average at least I was like
well what's average - she goes eight
inches and I was like no what do you
mean a [ __ ] 8-inch a fridge and you
know I may I may not be remembering the
number right but it was definitely not
above a below eight inches so I'm just
saying it needs to be conservative and I
was like eight inches I was like what
the [ __ ] are you talking what what's the
8-inch dick to you right and she goes
yeah she measured it out it was like
this big I was like that is not an
8-inch dick yeah I was like that is not
an 8-inch dick and she goes that's like
eight inches I was like this is not so
that means whoever she was [ __ ]
before it was telling her he had an
eight inch dick and that's what she was
[ __ ] with you know because size is
such an important thing so she's been
duped her whole [ __ ] life saying that
these dudes had like these huge slaw and
that's that's how that's how important
size is to guys to the point where they
would have to lie to a girl and
convinced him that their penis is eight
what she liked it either way so what the
[ __ ] did it matter about the size but to
hurt and she was describing her
boyfriend or the guy that she was
walking around before how big his dick
wasn't it was like this bro
unless you're a micropenis you know and
size really does not like bigger is not
better like it doesn't really matter
because I've had I [ __ ] I used to
date a dude that can [ __ ] his own belly
button if you wanted to Jesus Yeah right
and even that it was like it was kind of
hurts you know yeah the best sex ever
had was like this Filipino dude he had
like seven inches whatever it was the
best sex ever had but seven inches is
pretty sizable seven
yeah six or something yeah yeah like it
was it was average size you know and I
wasn't about sex ever had you know yeah
but like guys are always like oh the
bigger the better I'm like no dude like
what I was dating the guy
the huge one like Yoli you need to chill
there are things that we couldn't do my
organs my lungs do you understand
I'm dying [ __ ] I'm not yakitori okay
you're [ __ ] skewering the [ __ ]
[ __ ] on me relax alright yeah like it's
not about the size and people just like
it's porn because of porn games like
this unexpected sure I mean this um what
is it this this unrealistic expectations
like your dick doesn't have to be
mandingo do when I was a kid like I
remember when I watched porn and I saw
like these huge [ __ ] dicks I'm like
damn I was gonna be like that one right
and it ever happened and I was like how
come my penis isn't the size of my arm
what is going on I realize it in those
porns there's a lot of the you sleeves
that make yeah those things are gigantic
yeah dude if I were someone they would
one of those that I'm [ __ ] running
I'm like nah I'm good piece out these
girls organs wheelie our girls take that
dick like it's not very fine and it's
literally like the size of my arm it's
terrifying and they're and they look at
it like they grab it here they grab it
here and then they have another dick on
top of that and I'm like water
it's how did you even start doing is it
conditioning like I don't understand
yourself I mean they're just giving
birth consistently they must they must
love getting pregnant or something she
likes horrifying sucky the first time I
ever came was when I gave birth to a
child it finally happened and it's just
like it's like all right yeah cool you
can show it off whenever like a lot
there are so many guys that I met in the
past like oh yeah my dicks the [ __ ]
dick is a coke can I'm like that doesn't
turn me on
good size a [ __ ] Optimus Prime [ __ ]
I'll tear you in half
it's like what are you saying to me I
will slice you in half you'll be in a
[ __ ] grave in fact I'll put you in
two caskets cuz I'm a slice your body
you'll gain seven pounds just from the
big inside you what do you say real
quick scale okay
[Laughter]
so [ __ ] wild yeah man like I look
back on it now and you know that girl
who just [ __ ] wrecked my self-esteem
it was great because she gave me a lot
of pointers and she actually taught me
how to communicate very well so whenever
I had sex with a new partner you know
obviously not the first time but a
couple of times I thought oh that's like
yo so like what do you like thank you
you know say what guys should do yeah
but not every guys like me like no I'm
not like what say my gosh I should do
I'm telling you whoever's listening
right now be a courteous man and ask her
is there anything you want me to change
nobody's that good yeah yeah and you
know it also stemmed from the fact that
you know after that moment happened with
with this girl it was such a glass
shattering moment I had to reflect back
on the the previous sexual partners that
I had and how bad I was mhm
and I was a holy [ __ ] number one I never
asked
number two I didn't know what I was
doing and number three they were
fluffing up my ego yeah and I think it
was because I was with the the women
that I was very sexually active with
they were also very demure so they
didn't they didn't know how to
communicate and they never told me and
so I always had this problem of like not
knowing when they wanted to have sex
yeah because they would never tell me
they would never give me signs or
signals and it would always have to be
me doing something and then maybe they
were in the mood so I just never [ __ ]
knew yeah and it always felt weird you
know it's like okay are you in the mood
or not and so it just felt like I was
like I don't know it's hard
I don't know what am i attacking you am
I not what is going on right now right
so it just became very difficult and so
with this girl she was very confident
she was very straightforward you know
I'll be at that was probably one of the
reasons why we broke up because she
wanted too much sex but at least with
her she told me what she liked and she
didn't like him from that I always took
that and I moved on yeah and I asked
obviously if it's like a fling or
something like that if we just hooking
up real quick I don't have time I don't
have time to ask them know but women you
have to ask - because I am absolutely
yeah I learned that after a while Asia
people start forgetting how to initiate
sex yeah that's like in the beginning of
a relationship like I'll text you and
like yeah I'm coming home I'm gonna get
dig down
but after a while it's like like you
actually forget like how did I you say
initiate again yeah so strange and I
know a few couples right now that are
like a good friends of mine who are
actually going through that problem they
don't know how to initiate right now
into and then I'm actually still trying
to work on that too because after a
while in a relationship I forget how to
initiate so you expect the guy to
initiate more than you I know not really
like we I think we both kind of just
like get comfortable and just like hey
I'm tired it's like after a while I kind
of forget and it's hard like for me
though like I don't know maybe it's
because like I I guarantee you it's
because I grew up in a beauty supply
store but I think I'm a little I'm a
little probably more feminine than most
men are and it's just because like
number one like I can't have sex with my
partner unless they are completely in
the mood you can't have sex with me just
because you feel like I want it doesn't
feel good for me yeah it actually
bothers me it's it's it's very routine
it's very mediocre sex when somebody's
not in the mood it's extremely mediocre
and at that point you just try to get
your nut off so you must masturbate at
that point why the [ __ ] not so for me
like you just I I sounds kind of weird
and I guess like I do I need emotional
sex and I need to feel it so like that's
where you and I differ I can I
completely turn it off when I need to
exactly I so for me like I'm not like
that like I need to be obviously it's
for a guy is a lot easier to get me in
the mood you know but I don't want to be
in the mood and then the girls like oh
I'll just have sex for you I don't want
it then I actually have never in my life
what is it
Sall sex as a loving emotional thing
really emotional six it's only happens
it's only happened once and I swear to
God I cried after that's a good yeah it
was like because I was like I always see
movies and stuff like oh you're making
love I'm like I was making love I've
booked you know like yeah earmuffs like
I don't have like I don't make love I
[ __ ] you know it's just sex you know for
me it's like any relationship sex is sex
it's a physical thing right and it's
because like I something in my brain I
shut that off a long time ago yeah so
and the only thing is no it's actually
only happened one
and this was like a couple years ago
where me and this dude we were sitting
and we were laying in bed and we're just
listening to music going back an old R&B
and stuff like that and then a song came
on it was um was it half crazy yeah and
then for some reason like we just like
and then we actually made love and then
like during the time I was like oh my
god this is actually happening and then
I cried yeah and it was like the most
beautiful thing that's ever happened and
we had a conversation afterwards I told
and I explained him like this is why
it's important to me this is why I'm
crying and he completely understood and
that wasn't the first time it was like
it's like seeing a new color yeah it
took the strangest thing you know and I
explained to him like this is why and we
sat down we talked and then I was like
oh my god I think the moment that we
fell in love and it was awesome yeah and
like that's so like that happened at 28
years old yeah you know and that like at
28 that's super late yeah and it's so
far and few in between that I've
realized now if I don't feel that then
you're it's it's it's it's one of those
like it's not that you're not the one
for me but it's like I wouldn't be
surprised if I never felt it again
because it was so rare so I'm not gonna
like dismiss someone if I never feel
that with them well you know I think you
if you did feel that then you will fill
that with somebody else yeah they that's
tight that's like the reality of things
is like you you can't you can't really
forego the fact that you felt that you
can take it your mouth off so you can't
really forego the fact that you or
forget the fact that you felt that
because like that is in my personal
opinion and you know that's how I was
supposed to feel if before I got
together with Mariel I assumed that I
would never feel the way that I felt the
first time I ever got together with
anybody it was with my very first
girlfriend and because when I was with
that girl um it felt very pure it felt
like whenever I saw this girl like my
heart would flutter I would get nervous
and when I first kissed Mariel it felt
like that very first moment that I had
when I was when I was 18 years old again
and I had my very first kiss and so
people told me that you don't get that
again and I and I truly believed it I
was like oh yeah you don't get that
again so you know don't expect to feel
that way ever again about somebody just
know that it's going to be a different
experience
but when I kiss Muriel it was that
feeling all over again
and I was like oh [ __ ] this girl might
be something special yeah and so for you
to if you did feel that way with
somebody you should in my personal
opinion is it'll be so difficult for you
to go back into a relationship and not
feel that again yeah it'll be damn near
impossible because you'll look back and
say well how come I don't have that with
this person yeah it's always gonna be in
the back of your mind that's what it was
for me when I when I hooked up with
other girls or I got together with other
women and I didn't feel that and I kept
looking for it and I even though I was
trying to convince myself that it wasn't
gonna happen I still kept looking for it
over and over and then so when I felt
that again I was like oh this is
something that I have to hold on to and
so I mean the hard part about that is
that when you there's a double-edged
sword so once you find that now you know
that this person is in your life this
course can also hurt you now yes that's
the heart that was the hard part for
love is love is actually giving someone
the ability to hurt you and trusting
that they won't yeah emotional sex
though is something else man it was
crazy
like you this is everything just clicks
yeah and it just everything feels ten
times better yeah it was weird because
like every that success what it felt
like it just clicked and because before
I remember I was talking to my girl Mel
she's like I was so in love with my
boyfriend time when we had sex like
right now so he dumped [ __ ] that's okay
[ __ ] and then I finally happened and it
clicked and then me and him couldn't
describe it and then it was like three
days later because we couldn't figure
out how to word it and three days later
he texted me he's like I think this is
what it is and I messaged him feeling
like I think this is what it is - yeah
and also it's like holy [ __ ] this is
awesome but then like for me I'm just
like um I would say I'm a pessimist I'm
just not expecting it again you know I
mean like if it never happens again
cool whatever I'm not going to I don't
think you Rico I think once you
experience something like that is very
hard to be cool with it it's very very
difficult
I don't know because I've always been
like I'm kind of like it on my own you
know well it's not that you like it on
your own but if you I feel like if you
do get into another relationship and
then I do know that I do know that it's
gonna probably be like you if I get into
no another relationship or the people
that I meet I'm gonna keep looking for
that you know and I kind of like
came to the conclusion that I'm probably
gonna look for in the back of my mind
you know if it never happens and I'm
actually pretty okay with that too like
I'm not so sad though no it's all sad to
me because I like being by myself so
much you know I mean like I don't well
if you're by yourself it's okay but I'm
saying be with someone if I don't feel
that oh that's one saying with some
money and then you don't have that with
them then it's really sad if you buy
yourself that is gear by yourself
doesn't really [ __ ] matter yeah and I
think that's what my my my criteria or
whatever like one of the things that you
have to meet in my relationship now like
if I were to meet someone and if I'd
never feel that it's like you're
probably not who I want to be with you
know oh for sure I mean it's hard to
look back on a relationship where you
don't feel that intense emotion at least
once I mean even for me like people
always say you know I I have a lot of
friends who won't say a lot of friends
I'd say there's a couple of people who I
look at their relationship and I kind of
use them as an example of something I
don't want because they're they are with
the person that they're with and they
only and they always say things that
it's not a joke it's very disparaging
like they say stuff like you know like
it's never gonna be the same like when
you first started going out with them
like you know like it was super
passionate it was all fire and like I
thought I missed those days and for me
like when I'm with Mario like I don't
miss those days at all and in fact like
I think what we have is 10 times better
and I don't say it just to say it like I
want to go back to when we first started
going out I didn't know who she was I
didn't know what she liked we fought so
[ __ ] often because we butted heads
because I didn't understand her heart I
didn't understand her as a human being
and she didn't understand me if I have
to go back and go through I [ __ ] that
[ __ ] I'll kill myself I'm not doing that
again what we have now is so [ __ ]
good and it took four years to build
that [ __ ] and I realized that if I don't
have that let's say Mary Alice resulted
Mary leaves me I'm done I'm single I'm
single for the rest of my life like I'm
not doing this all over again I'm gonna
be writing [ __ ] so much poetry about
this [ __ ] I'm going out of curly
mustache I'm gonna have that French ass
happen to me some [ __ ] baguettes have
some coffee smoke cigars I am in Laval
I have to do my app and because she
broke my I told them dude I was like yo
I told Muriel two things already I tell
her this on a consistent basis like you
ever [ __ ] leave me I guarantee you I
will never get back to somebody else and
you're gonna ruin me
yeah live with that on your conscience
number two don't you [ __ ] die before
me I'm dying before you I tell her that
every day I know you don't [ __ ] die
before me I'm dying before you she goes
why cuz I was like cuz if you die before
me I'm going to die yeah I think if I
die before you be fine yeah not in a bad
way I'm just saying you're stronger
you're emotionally stronger than I am
you [ __ ] leave me my life is over
doing I will [ __ ] don't you [ __ ]
leave me dude like I'm very hyper
dependent on you emotionally now yeah
you know it [ __ ] sucks
yeah that's why what so I've been
actually going to therapy yeah and I
like it a lot because I'm learning more
and more about myself and I there's
something that I always knew about
myself that I need to work on was that I
have like no patience and I am a runner
which is really the [ __ ] movie
runaway bride a [ __ ] runner so like
for you like you guys were arguing like
crazy in the beginning of an F before
you figured it out right yeah if I'm
arguing the beginning I'm like oh [ __ ]
like if all those red flags are there I
get scared and I take off yeah and so
that is that's usually what happens like
that's what happened with the guy that I
was dating it's like after a while we
crew kind of complacent and he said feel
like a roommate to me yeah I was like oh
well that's kind of you know like maybe
we're not you know and then after we
broke up I was like I should probably
work on myself and that's like where I
am now yeah and and it's dope because I
have like you guys like yeah I have like
older peers you know they can teach me
like have you guys have Jen Jess I would
you and Barton there at least like no
you gotta [ __ ] like you got a stick
and work on it and like be more patient
and you know don't freak out at the
first sign of whatever so I've been
working on it and it's you know it's
just like but you know there is a sign
of like you you'll understand who's is
terrible
yeah who's worth that time because
sometimes people didn't work on
something then there's nothing that'll
work exactly and that's what I was
scared of for the longest time like what
am I here for like what if I waste like
ten years on this and I'm like [ __ ]
40 years old I'm divorced you know but
it's it's
I think it also comes from I think it's
really important that parents should
teach their children like what a healthy
relationship is what proper conflict
resolution is because for me I never had
parents around to teach me that right
yeah so what I learned about love was
from like movies and and like fairy
tales and and so in my mind growing up I
was like well if I don't feel
butterflies and blah blah blah and like
know that he's the one right when I feel
he's probably not and now just take off
yeah so I think it's really important
that you know like parents don't like
hold your kids back from like oh no
don't hang out with boys like don't have
sex whatever just don't whatever ever
you know yeah and they should teach you
like this is where a healthy
relationship is this is what you do with
like conflict coffee resolution this is
what you should be in a relationship
what you should not expect what you
should expect you know what I mean and I
didn't have that growing up and I was
talking to my brother it will you got it
and he was just a boy yes so well
[ __ ] Fruitopia aids boy I [ __ ]
love but I was talking to will he's like
oh [ __ ] cuz I told him about my therapy
sessions and sadly I'm like and I told
McGill I'm trying to be a better person
this is what I learned he goes oh [ __ ]
cuz he came from a broken family too
he's like I never learned about that and
I think that's the reason why I can't be
in relationships and I'm like yeah and
you know like that's what I'm trying to
work on right now it's hard because now
you you you are all so I'm gonna take
this with the grain of salt but it's
you're at a disadvantage now because now
you have to find a guy that has to be
understanding and willing to take on
that baggage and and that's really what
it is like I you know when I got
together with Mariel she had to take all
my baggage and I to take on hers as well
and a lot of people don't don't
understand that yeah like their problems
are literally your problems like you you
have to help them out with it when they
need it the most and it's very difficult
because it's easy to be dismissive it's
easy to say that's your [ __ ] problem
you deal with it when you deal with it
you come back to me when you're [ __ ]
normal yeah and it just doesn't work out
that way like like I have a lot of
personal problems that Muriel has helped
me out with like specifically like my
anger issue she's helped me out so much
with that [ __ ]
and with her too like she actually had
her ideal man like built in her head
through these [ __ ] Disney movies and
his [ __ ] fairy tales and it turned
out her [ __ ] prince charming is a fat
Korean guy she just was like shattered
she's like what is this why do I love
this guy she's not prince charming like
he's [ __ ] hyper opinionated he argues
with me all the time he challenges me
all the time he doesn't open the door he
[ __ ] leave the toilet seat up you
know and I'm like yo that's that's not
what love is like you don't you're not
gonna love me for those reasons you know
you're gonna love me because there's
something special between us yeah and
it's something that you really can't
explain and you can't put your finger on
and I told it with her - I didn't expect
to be with somebody like you but I am
with somebody like you yeah you know and
at the end of the day like I found out
for myself that I can't live without you
now so what are you gonna do about it is
just because I don't fit into this mole
are you gonna run away from it and
absolutely she wasn't gonna do that so
for her it was a big thing it was a huge
thing for her to figure out like oh [ __ ]
everything that I read up on it's it's
not realistic in the sense of that's a
good thing she goes those relationships
don't exist and even if they did I
wouldn't like it yeah alright because I
thought I would like a very very what's
it called agreeable human being so I was
with a very agreeable girl before I she
used to bore the [ __ ] [ __ ] on me my
god dude there are times where I knew I
was wrong I should just like you're
probably right I'm like you [ __ ]
serious [ __ ] you spineless [ __ ] how
did hear you I mean I can't believe you
said I was right yeah how [ __ ] dare
you and then you know I I ended up
breaking up with her and for her I think
it was hard for understand because she
in her mind she goes I felt like I did
everything right you know what I look at
Mary you know Mary Lee you know what I
think right she's gonna be a [ __ ]
dope mother off or she'd be the kind of
mom that I would be scared of like
that's if that was my mom I'd be scared
cuz I feel like she can be really Stern
oh for sure dude mom she would be a
great mom didn't like even for me right
now let's say I somehow knocked up Mary
all right now I wouldn't mind yeah she
would mind she's not ready for a kid but
I'm saying like for me like I would I
wouldn't mind having me I totally see
her as a mom she's awesome I could see
myself as a mom it's okay but speaking
of my brother aids boy he actually
messaged me out of nowhere he goes
people are messaging me aids boy did you
and David talk about it again
how's like oh [ __ ] yeah we did sorry god
that's so [ __ ] funny dude I love it
like he so did I tell you what this
section the sweetest gift that anyone
has ever given me so this was over
Christmas and then you called me up I
was I was actually visiting my dad he
called me up he's like yo Merry
Christmas so I was thinking about like I
don't know what to get a girl who
already has everything that she wants
and he get home I go when's that crank
so he gave me so when when I was younger
I was separated from my dad he had to
move for like work or whatever and then
him or he went with his second wife
which is wills mom yeah and we'll got to
live with him and grow up with him I
never got I never got that I know I
didn't have like those memories right
now so will told me he's like what do I
give a girl that has everything she's
ever wanted I'm going to call you like
once a week or someone money cuz I'm
gonna give you memories that I have of
debt raising me and like yeah and like
just like little things like little
stories if I'm gonna tell you a story
every week and it was like the sweetest
thing like i sat there and I cried at
the dinner table is like you're right I
didn't have any of these stories you
know like this is my dad like I'm like
we're barely spending time now yeah in
the last I want to say like six years
because I finally started make enough
money to not like him to not be a burden
to my like I always felt like I don't
want to make my dad buy me you know so I
couldn't visit in the longest time and
then so I started making money and I can
finally like be a daughter you know my
brother called me up he's like I'm gonna
teach you or like I'm gonna I'm gonna
tell you all these stories that I have
with that nice Antonio like all these
stories and it's like I finally have a
childhood with my dad again yeah stupid
aids boys the best Christmas present
I've ever had and it's and like the
first and then the best thing is I get
to hear these stories and then I go to
my dad away dad do you remember this
he's a hey I remember that I did this
like my dad stole [ __ ] basketball
hoop like a big one that make sense
your father scares me
hi I'm not I'm not gonna deny that story
happened your father looks like a thief
of joy recently was um well he was at my
uncle's workplace right there was a no
it was my uncle is it was somewhere like
a somewhere I don't know where it was
but he's like this big basketball hoop
yeah and he remembered that will and my
other little brother when they were
playing basketball in the back we were
kind of poor and he would get like it
just like a bass Eagles red plastic back
there like the hard plastic basket yeah
they would use it as a hoop and my dad
would felt bad so he saw his hoop and he
told my uncle's like hey and my uncle is
so nice like no we can't do that
and then will says cuz we'll say I was
in the car that time I heard them
talking about it
and then no no don't steal it the next
morning I woke up there was a new hoop
in our yard and dad's like walking
around holding his back because like
he's hit the night before he took the
truck and he lifted that thing and put
on his on the truck and it hurt his back
and then he brought it home to will and
then he and then will a night like one
eye really close and he's you know he's
like and that's what dad is he does
these crazy things out of love you know
and it's just like exactly what he's
Robin Hood he stole from other kids
story that's very sweet for the kind of
scary at the same time I stole from me
there's other children my children it's
like I feel bad for these are the kids
but yeah I remember that I couldn't walk
for the whole day yeah because I wanted
to get that for my kids you know and
it's just like that was the best present
because now I kind of get like a taste
of what it's like to have a dad you know
cuz you oh you were with your you were
with your grandparents okay
my dad was away for a long time so I
grew up with grandparents and like you
know I felt kinda bad I grew up and I
told my like my dad would always tell me
like hey you know move to Missouri with
me I'm like Missouri when I was young
and I was stupid and like no dad I want
to make it in LA I love it here you know
and I remember telling my dad - it was
like don't worry
because he's always I want to take care
of you my dad you know I never needed
you before I don't know and I didn't
mean that in a malicious way of course
yeah yeah you seem like you I'm
self-sufficient like you not to worry
you know and so I grew up without you
know like a dad I didn't grow like I
didn't have and like I said I never
wanted to bother him for money so um the
only time that he actually um there I
can give you two times and my dad gave
me money or something it was to buy my
first car it was at $3,000 shit-ass
Honduras yeah that my uncle met my other
uncle sold to me and he's one of those
[ __ ] like like Chinese uncles Oh screw
his own [ __ ] family so it was like a
piece-of-shit car so that's one and then
there's one other time where I
miscalculated which bills to pay first
cuz I was [ __ ] dirt poor right and I
was living by myself and um and I
realized [ __ ] I don't have money pasted
on my dad I took the kinda like bailed
me out with a little bit of money but
other than that I didn't want to bother
him he had his you know he had his other
marriage and he had a bunch of kids to
take care of I was the eldest one I felt
like a piece of [ __ ] if I had to ask for
money and so I it was rough dude like I
remember having to figure out like what
bills I pay and then I kind of resented
other kids like Danby grew up with
parents like I couldn't pay for an oil
change and that's exactly how my car
actually eventually died yeah and I
couldn't pay for an oil change and I
would sit there I'm like you know you
know if I had a family like my dad would
probably pay for my old change but I
didn't want to bother him yeah and then
I remember when I car died I cried my
eyes out because I didn't know what to
do but now that I've grown older I
started making money I was like I spend
every Christmas with my dad I spent my
birthday with my dad
I spent I try to spend his birthday with
him too you know and I'm trying to do as
much as I can because now I live in
constant fear running out of time like I
am so scared if please my dad that's
like the biggest thing that I'm scared
if I would go [ __ ] about anything else I
mean you two little sister she's just as
emotional as me I told her that I put
her as my beneficiary this one started
almost crying she does not like it when
I talk about you like that but yeah so
now I live in constant fear of running
out of time why is because you're
getting older like that like I feel that
all the time too like that's that's like
something that's you know living with is
I grew up with both my parents right and
so like from number one I don't have a
lot of family here like I have very few
like blood relatives
you know how close I am to my mom like
you know I talked to my mom almost every
day and so like even for me like the
thought of like being in traffic and the
first thing I do is call my mom because
I just want to talk to her like there's
gonna be a time when I don't have that
there's gonna be a time where I'm gonna
wake up and I'm gonna want to eat
something that she made it's not gonna
be there like I have to really come to
terms with these things and I'll do it I
thought about it I think I might kill
myself it's hard because like you know
that's the part where we grow old and we
try not to take things for granted
anymore and if you're a young person and
you're listening to this it's even if I
tell you this you're not gonna [ __ ]
get it and it's it's not it's not any
fault it's no fault area you're just
young and it may sound stupid to you
right now but when you get a little
older you'll start to understand this
because it does start to hurt because
everything in your mind is forever to
you when you're young everything is
forever
and mom and dad will always be here oh
they're invincible but the moment you
see your parents bleed you see them hurt
it kind of snaps everything into reality
you know like I only see my dad only
like two three times a year right yeah
and I remember seeing him getting gray
hairs for the first time when he stopped
dyeing his hair and that's when it hit
me like a [ __ ] ton of bricks so I
made it a point to I sat him down with a
camera and I had him tell me his whole
entire life story because I know that
I'm gonna need that many passes you know
so yeah like kids now like they don't
like you said it's not it's not that
their fault like you just you're just
young and everything is just like I said
is everything is forever right now and
it's hard man and the good thing is is
like you you realize it now because a
lot of people don't even have that
opportunity they do it when their
parents are on their deathbed and that's
the sad part like my dad and I like what
I've talked about on this podcast before
my dad and I didn't get along a lot but
now we do a lot better now and because I
can't waste that time with him it's very
difficult my father and I didn't have a
great relationship because he and I are
actually very very similar yeah you know
I had I but I always had my desk so I'm
very fortunate right and in your case -
it's a good thing that you realized that
but you know there you are gonna have to
come to terms with the fact that he is
gonna go away and it's gonna be hard it
was hard it was hard for me and my
grandma my grandma actually was the
other half that that raised me growing
up and so my grandma a lot of people
don't know this but my grandma she was
like in hospice care so she was like fed
through tubes she had the whole thing
and she just couldn't speak or anything
else like that
and because my parents were at work all
the time when I was in Sacramento I had
to go visit her almost every day just to
make sure that they were because you
don't know if they're gonna take care of
her right or not yeah so I would check
up on her see if she's okay check up on
her see if she's okay and I had to watch
my grandma just like wither away every
day before she passed away and that's it
was so hard for me and so when she
passed away because I already dealt with
her leaving during the funeral it was a
lot easier for me because I to me once
once she couldn't speak anymore she
wasn't here anymore and so I remember
that time where she just couldn't talk
and I just died like I think I was
crying for like almost like six seven
months straight yeah but that's at a
while I was able to deal with it because
now that I know that she's not here it
it's easier for me so because like one
of the hardest things that I deal with
like I remember every now and then her
consciousness would come back but when
it would come back she would couldn't
figure out why she was here so she would
just wake up it she'll scream crying and
that should you still [ __ ] wreck me
like I remember like like one of the
nurses told me like Oh your grandma's
like her crying last night I'm like [ __ ]
and so I would go and see her and then
she couldn't talk you know okay why I
couldn't be there then so I would always
check up every day to see if she was
okay but the hard part about that is
that you just you just have to
understand this is part of life and
thinking that it's not going to happen
it doesn't change anything you know so
like for me and my parents like seeing
my grandma just like that just always
wrecked me I might do as she wasn't the
best to me either
I probably just beat my [ __ ] ass yo
she is to [ __ ] me up yeah but I think
like because family is such an important
thing is why I I like I I have a family
type of mentality and everything that I
do even the way I carry French so you're
not different for 78 years and I love
you like a sister you know so like I've
always kind of kept that like familial
love with everything that I haven't I
had that because I grew up in a good
home and I from my grandma's death I
kind of realized like you do have to be
prepared for when these things happen
and to think that it's not going to it's
just gonna hurt you in the long run and
so with my mom like I think about it
sometimes too like there's gonna be a
time where I won't be able to talk to on
the phone and that [ __ ] scares me
[ __ ] scares me because it's fruity
it's like a almost a daily part of my
life and like there's gonna be a time
where I'm being trafficked I'm gonna
call somebody here nobody's gonna be
there yeah and it's gonna [ __ ] wreck
me I think about this [ __ ] and it kills
me on the inside but yeah you know my
mom knows it too like she understands
like she always talks about her dying
and stuff like that but you know there's
like I'm gonna die shut the [ __ ] up dude
why you say this [ __ ] there's like
midweek yeah but like you know my mom is
just like that's why I think like the
cool thing is like because we've we've
grown up and we're maturing now we can
we really start to live for others
instead of ourselves and it feels great
yeah like instead of having all these
like selfish wants and needs now the
things that you want offer the people
that you love instead and it kind of
blows my mind a little bit could I never
thought I would be like that and so like
I shared it was so funny this is a
second time I'm tearing up the podcast
with Mariel today and we're talking
about haha we're talking about this
moment where I started like crying
because like my I scared my mom and this
is me as an adult because I used to get
in a lot of fistfights as a kid and a
lot of violent [ __ ] to like us like
hyper violent stuff yeah and I always
joke about me being a [ __ ] and stuff
which I have now for sure a hundred
percent I didn't trust me you try to
fight me on running away but you know
like I took a lot of just like
counseling and therapy for me to get rid
of my anger issues and I used to have
very very bad thoughts like in terms of
light when somebody would anger me like
I would think about murdering them you
know and like that kind of stuff was
embedded in my head from these guys that
are you staying out with where they
would they would tell me that if you get
into a fight and somebody tries to touch
you and you're not thinking about
killing them they're gonna kill you
first
and so that's how I used to think about
fights and but because of that they [ __ ]
me up in my head so when I get angry and
I see someone in confrontation comes out
I think I got to [ __ ] kill this dude
because if he doesn't he's gonna kill me
first and there's such a stupid thought
it's such a terrible thing to think
about and I remember not to repeat a
story but basically like my mom heard me
on the phone kind of go red line and
then I saw her in the car she just said
my name and it was you've so
disappointed I [ __ ] broke down
like oh [ __ ] like I'm putting my mom
through that same [ __ ] again when I was
a kid where she was afraid I was gonna
die and then I heard it in her voice and
it [ __ ] wreck me yeah you know so
those are the type of things that you
get when you're older you know and so
it's kind of a it's a coming to Jesus
moment for us you know as I know [ __ ]
like things are finite and you have to
make sure that these moments last
because I've been seeing you laying out
with your dad a lot more you've been
flying flying out more with those stupid
goofy dumb dogs I love them yeah it's
like and that you know that's the same
thing that you went through is what my
dad's going through my dad was [ __ ]
he was a wild Oh your dad was nothing
like your father but you know I was like
I'm like a very watered down version of
your dad extremely watered down you know
my dad's [ __ ] while do like I know
it's a few years ago you got into a
fight with a dude and my mom is the only
one that can calm him down like yeah but
she has it like she's only wild like if
she would've grabbed him by his shoulder
and said honey that's when he calms down
because he realized I got a [ __ ] ton of
kids you know oh yeah yeah so it's it's
it's crazy like it's crazy when you're
right when you grow up you start living
for other people because then that's
what he did cuz when he was younger he
was dumb and this all's about him and I
don't get what [ __ ] about me and then he
had kids he had me and his life changed
for me when I was younger it was like I
was so focused on myself because I'm
like I need to work I need to do this
how am I gonna pay this bill I can't go
see them right now I'm [ __ ] I have to
work you know but now I have like I can
take care of myself and that's when I
started realizing like I've been not
that I've been wasting my time but [ __ ]
I wish I spent more time with my parents
and I'm doing now I have a rule actually
that I implemented it's that if I ever
talk about my dad or even if the thought
just crosses my mind if he even crosses
my mind I just messaged him like hey I
love you
yeah and we do that like all the time
and you know like Asian parents are not
very affectionate of course then yeah he
likes it that he pretty no but then he
like he has affectionate to me he's like
I learned to you know like so throughout
like you'll see him lightly he's on
Facebook he's like he's [ __ ] all
about face yeah so on facebook Messenger
like all you see the messages back and
forth is I love you I love you - I love
you I love you - I love you I love you -
and then like some conversation in
between
yeah and that's like I think that's
really important one
your parents like you don't live with
your parents you know yeah and it's like
you don't have to I think a lot of kids
don't do it because it's so awkward like
I don't want to call them and just like
have a lot of conversations you know and
that's why I just messed when I came
just want to let you know I love you you
know and it's it's it's done a world of
wonder for my mind in my dad's
relationship cuz I've been wanting that
relationship for so long and it's
finally here you know and that's
actually part of the reason why I
haven't celebrated my birthday at all
it's because going just spend it with my
dad but this time I'm gonna have a party
and then I'm going to my dad that's kind
of crazy man like it's an you know wheel
you know it kind of wraps back to like
where I was talking about even like
probably how you've dealt with your
relationships has a lot to do with your
family life growing up you know and all
this stuff too and this is all you know
I say baggage but it's not in a negative
way but it's just everything that comes
with being with somebody it's the wire
is what you are is the life story and
you have to be understanding of this
because there's probably a situation
with whoever guess whoever is gonna be
in a serious relationship with you
they're probably gonna run the problem
with you because of the way that you
were raised and you're not gonna be able
to like emotionally connect with them
and they're gonna have to learn how to
be patient and understand that you
didn't grow up with the same things that
they did yeah so like love and affection
like a stable father figure maybe
sometimes even stable mother figure in
your life you know true I remember so
I'm exactly with my dad when I'm angry
I'm [ __ ] like you need to leave me
alone you know if you keep pushing at me
it's gonna get real ugly and it's true
like I I dated a guy once where whenever
he we argued he would just be like well
I need you to tell me that you love me
or like I need you to be like you know
come over here and show me some
affection but I'm I'm so pissed that I
can't do that but he never understood
that you know I mean and like that's and
that's where it comes to when it comes
to understanding you need to understand
how people are like how their past is my
past is I'm just like my dad
yeah you can't change that you know and
it's just one of those things you have
to figure out how to work with it or you
know like it's it's it's not one of
those things where it's like it's gonna
make or break us and I didn't think and
usually why I just need you to come and
give me a hug I'm like dude right now I
want to call your [ __ ] eyes out yeah
you know you can't do that let me chill
out for a second yeah like that's that's
that's my baggage you know and it like
you said you have to find someone
actually understands that and can
take on that baggage and not like always
try to change me all the time I always
get worried with who you're gonna be
with like I work for that guy and then I
also like wonder like I'm gonna like the
guy it's such a weird thing with you
with you too like I always think like
the [ __ ] who the [ __ ] is you know I
guess always better well one guy I dated
you knew him that was your friend
yeah the other guy - I met him - he's a
really nice guy but like I always in the
back of my mind I'm like you ain't [ __ ]
like I always had this like really weird
feeling about guys that you're with and
I'm I think it's really funny because
the guys that I date are people who
never expect what I would date because I
remember I went to my best friend's
wedding it was her bridesmaid and I
brought my boyfriend at the time alone
you met him yeah and she liked all the
groomsmen like everybody knows who I am
yeah like you know they didn't they know
like oh it's Gina darling whatever [ __ ]
you every and one of them she told me
later and she's like you know the guys
actually came over the groomsmen came
over to me and said I did not think that
that would be the type of guy that she
dates cuz they're thinking I'm dating
some like [ __ ] like rich douchey dude
like all these tattoos I was a nice
Filipino guy you know yeah yeah like
that's what people people don't really
know what I date and honestly if you put
all nice boy friends in a line they all
look completely different they're a
little bit different what do you think
what do you think is like what would you
accept for me I don't know I don't think
anybody's good enough for you that's why
that's that's the problem - like it's
like I almost don't want to meet them
because I'm gonna judge them off the bat
yeah because I'm already like but you
ain't [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah so like it
always it always bothers me ya know so
it's like oh [ __ ] man who the [ __ ] is
this guy you know what I mean and it's
such a bad habit to have you know musics
I've known you for so [ __ ] long you
know so like and I always want you to be
happy
you know and sometimes I feel like for
you to like you you want to be happy but
in your case because a lot of the things
that you've grown up with and a lot of
things you had to deal with you you kind
of don't know what happiness is right
now and so like you're looking for that
and I can't find that for you and it's
kind of sad for me because I can't do
that for you you know and so with these
guys too sometimes I feel like these
guys aren't equipped for it it's like
like I feel like hopefully I'll you know
when you bring a guy around and I see
him and I'm like he he's a Moute he need
an emotionally intelligent guy yeah and
it's kind of hard to find nowadays like
it's really hard to find an emotionally
intelligent woman or man you know and
I'm not saying I'm the best at it
but maybe it's just because my mom I
have such a close relationship with my
mom and I was very fortunate of that
that maybe I grew up with kind of like
you know I had like those really
thuggish friends but I also had my
really sweet mom I talked to every day
so she kind of balanced me out a lot but
you know like I do understand you do
have a lot of things that you're dealing
with so you need a guy that couldn't
really understand that [ __ ] and if they
don't and they're going to just really
be dismissive of it I just did bothers
me it bothers me a lot it's like yo you
can't you have to take everything that
comes with her and you have to be able
to help her to support her in that kind
of sense and I feel like some guys just
they don't see it they see a pretty girl
yeah they see a girl who's really funny
that's really great to be around but
then when you have your bad moments
they're like I can't deal with it and I
hate that [ __ ] because they they only
expect you to be your persona yeah I
think people expect that too because
it's what they've seen you know and they
don't I've met guys in the past we're
like they don't they're not ready to
deal with what's about to happen because
yeah I thought when you said they're
like you're scared fit was because I was
gonna rip them apart oh that too that's
it for sure you guys that's what I'm
saying you got to be ready for
everything yeah and the things that I
went through my past I get it's a lot
you know it's a one I'm still working on
it too you know and then and I think
that's why I think it's that that's why
I decided to finally go to therapy yeah
because I realized that I'm turning 30
and like I'm not I don't feel any rush
like get married and stuff like that
because I never really thought about it
you know yeah but I think what really
triggered it was I actually had like
it's very far for you and few between
like it's so rare I had a breakdown like
a really bad breakdown right and the one
before that was just so far away I was
like I probably got handled but when
that came back around I was like [ __ ] I
never figured this out you know because
in my mind she's like I can deal with it
I've dealt with plenty of [ __ ] before
and I'm fine and then this is what I
realized like I need to actually go and
talk to someone about this and so this
whole past year of being 29 years old
has been I've been going to therapy and
I'm trying to figure it out and I
learning that I don't need anyone around
me right now I really love just being by
myself and learning more about myself
and and learning how to deal with the
issues that I have and stuff you know
it's good and people don't really
appreciate that a lot they don't
appreciate they're a long time because I
was I think aside from my serious
relationships are like dating here and
there I I genuinely like being single
just because number one I wasn't mature
enough to be in a relationship because
all I did was thinking about I was I
only thought about myself in my career I
didn't have space for that right and a
lot of people didn't get it they're like
you know it's great to be with somebody
else like I know it's great to be with
somebody but I am ready for that [ __ ]
so it won't be great for me it won't be
great for them either they're not gonna
like it that's what I did I kept forcing
myself into relationships cuz I thought
it would like it would be awesome I'll
be fine
and I would force my problems onto them
yeah yeah it's just it's just a lot to
deal with but I'm glad that you're
getting better too like its I'm telling
you man everybody needs that like coming
to Jesus moment and now I know and
you're just happy yeah you're actually
having it pretty young though to be
honest with you like it like 29 like t
be surprised do you be so [ __ ]
surprised man aging nothing that's what
they mean by aging really nothing about
a number because there's a lot of dudes
that do that I know for sure they're
still dealing with their demons right
now and and they refuse to address it
you know they don't want to ask for help
they don't want to go to therapy do you
think therapy's for [ __ ] [ __ ] or
crazy people all right bro you're just
doing your problems man and you know
I'll be there to let you know when I'm
ready to hear you out but if you keep
telling yourself that there's no
problems and then you're just gonna have
to just live with those demons for the
rest of your life it's like a routine
check-up for your body and everything oh
for sure you know and I think a lot of
people do get therapy outside of just
like traditional therapy they don't even
know it you don't even [ __ ] know it
yeah it's like when you have that really
close friend or for me as my mom you
know she like helps me just listens to
me and helps me solve these problems out
and it's crazy that's like my version of
therapy and I didn't realize that I had
like consistent therapy it's just wasn't
in that traditional form right so yeah
Wow look at that dude in now in 30
minutes in
[ __ ] killing the podcast game just
[ __ ] making me cry and [ __ ] it I just
cried today I told you you [ __ ]
unlock this this water tap movie yeah
everything's making me cry dude look at
everything this their podcast I've
gotten so many tags and messages about
watching along with the gods and how I
ruined them do you this is one girl she
was watching with her boyfriend and she
was yelling her boyfriend like why the
[ __ ] I do cry cuz she's like solving her
eyes up cuz I told people attack me when
they like in like stories I can suffer I
made my sister watch it to actually
crack oh yeah I sin Chi videos she was
crying in my bed she was pissed and then
I watched him I mean I watched change
Busan - OH - train to Pusan at the end
with the daughters yeah oh did you
I think you shut up that's cuz she was
emotionally spent from the first movie
that's why that's the hard part
yeah like you you watch train to Pusan
first then you watch along with the guys
yeah what the [ __ ] yeah I actually
posted on Twitter that I'm making a
watch a train to Busan yeah I'm David
Rees when he's like you'll leave that
girl alone leave her alone man what's
wrong with you I'm pretty sure she wants
to be happy like [ __ ] you showed macho
Libre or something dude because I know
my sister she cries easy and I just
wanted to I wanted to make her watch it
so [ __ ] funny well guys that ends
another episode of the genius brain
podcast you know I didn't expect the
conversation to go that way but that's
the like-like-like so what are the most
emotional podcasts that we've had yeah
do that [ __ ] dude you don't know how
long they're they're gonna be around and
if you don't have parents mmm call
somebody somebody yeah just tell them
you love them somehow but anyways guys
you could you could check out the genius
of a podcast on every audio platform
were talking about cashbox Spotify we're
talking about the iTunes Spotify is the
cast box and everything else in the
stitchers but yeah man let us be on your
commute we just want to have this is
like like I mentioned before it's a
podcast literally about nothing we're
here to really interview people we're
just here to be along with you guys and
have dope conversation have you guys
kind of peeping you guys are the UH what
do you call it the fly on the wall that
gets to observe some of the dopest
conversations on the Internet's muffs
earmuffs
earmuffs [ __ ]
crazy but yeah give us a thumbs up and
if you're on that iTunes stuff make sure
you give us a five star and you already
know Gina's gonna come back here cuz
she's she's she's like probably one of
the best Oh follow you in my stream - oh
yeah shadow all your stuff right now
please I stream video games on Facebook
so if you guys wanna check me on its
Facebook comm / I heart Gina I scream
like five days a week cuz if you guys
want to come play some games me talk
[ __ ] hangout on there and follow me on
instagram is Gina darling I need some
sponsorships what's up yeah so if you
love the conversations that we're having
here she has these type of conversations
on her [ __ ] stream so check her out
it's it's [ __ ] hilarious I love you
[ __ ] love you peace